[Music]
oh hi with whom am i speaking
Oh Johnny dobby Johnny huh I think you
know who I am
I'm Helen I was in your store the other
day and I gave you a request for a
certain pepperidge farm cookie for the
macadamia crunch did you get that for me
when did wait I have to blow my nose I
have a cold excuse me I'm sorry Johnny
nature calls
all right um it was sometime last week I
ordered the cookie you're the handsome
one aren't you yeah how old are you
darling wait
27 that's what I thought I'm that very
attractive older woman that flirts with
you all the time
you know who I am you know I listen
here's what I want Johnny okay I want
you to deliver the cookies to me
personally and I want you to just you
know just between you and me and the
devil I like to be sprayed in the mug so
I want to take the cookies I want to
crunch them up all over me and I want
you to lick amour for me what do you say
to that
you heard me Johnny no I'm not kidding
you
I want you to grab a jar of that man
gravy and I want it all over my my
behind what my husband doesn't service
me anymore Johnny do you understand what
I'm saying and you're a very attractive
man I come in there all the time I asked
for the cookies remember I ordered the
cookies and you said you would get them
for me and now what I want is I want you
to deliver them to me personally okay
and I'll make you feel very good Johnny
are you married maybe you need to come
by and talk to me you want me to come by
in person I'd be very happy to come and
touch you sure come on talk to me I'll
come by today if I know you'll be there
I'll be here for the rest day will you
tell me if you're married or not
well the sketch that we get here no I
wanted to I want to know if it's worth
my time
not Johnny that's what I'm gonna tell
you me really you have I find you very
sexy with that voice all right because
now let me tell you something that you
don't know I have false teeth when I
take them out I could make you feel so
good you won't know what hit you I'll
have a cookie and you all at once and
then you could have my cookies
all right okay I'm gonna come talk to
you Johnny I'll be over there is this
still you yeah I know you sexy as all
get-out Johnny that's why I asked for
you you know what I'm tired you want me
to come down no better all right I'll be
there any minute all right
all right darling goodbye